mr. president mr. president mr. vice
president with that the Speaker of the
US House of Representatives sent the
message this was no ordinary send-off
this was no ordinary congressman Elijah
Cummings the longtime Democratic leader
he was known as the party's moral voice
two former presidents celebrated what
they called his very American story
his parents were sharecroppers from the
south they picked tobacco and
strawberries and then sought something
better in this city South Baltimore it's
not even a teenager when he hauled down
to the swimming pool and joins a group
to integrate it and for his trouble gets
banged on the head with a glass model
living on a lifetime scar he was a civil
rights activist that often promoted his
hometown Baltimore a majority-black City
in 2017 as riots consumed those streets
with protests against police brutality
Cummings took to the streets with a
megaphone to send a message of call but
his final months would find him in the
center of a presidential storm Cummings
led the committee investigating
president Donald Trump's conduct and
Trump lashed out as he often does on
Twitter the president calling Baltimore
disgusting rodent and rat infested
Cummings Widow responded congressman
Cummings did was not easy and it got
infinitely more difficult in the last
months of his life when he sustained
personal attacks and attacks on his
beloved City
and while he carried himself with grace
and dignity in all public forums it hurt
him the underlying message of the entire
hours long service comings spent his
life trying to perfect the promise of
this democracy which he saw in his final
years as being under threat
well we're dancing with the Angels the
question will be asked in 2019 what do
we do to make sure we kept our democracy
intact did we stand on the sidelines and
say nothing
patty : al Jazeera Washington